[Music]
speaking of poetic justice oh something
we love yeah
greek police have arrested a man
who was allegedly filmed kicking a cat
into the sea while dining at an outdoor
room
like a [ __ ] soccer kick like doing
like that you had to do a soccer kick
how's she gonna get that [ __ ] in the
sea like
oh
what other kind of
in gross footage shared on social media
three people
can be seen sitting at a seafront eatery
when they're approached by two felines a
member of the party then entices one of
the cats to the water's edge with a fish
before kicking the animal oh my wow
that's [ __ ] dog that's premeditated
yeah it's like first the whole thing say
don't [ __ ] with cats man they do not
flop okay that's a good documentary um
if charged though
he could face up to 10 years in prison
holy [ __ ] the cat's going to drop the
charges yeah right yeah
did the cat die did the cat die uh no
cat's still swimming
yeah silver lining
he's like this ain't so bad
because i know cats hate water
but they could swim though they could
swim
so he could also be slapped with a
maximum fine of 50 000 euros whoa that's
a pretty high five and according to the
outlet the cat was found to be unharmed
after being taken to the vet by locals
okay oh that's cool but imagine how
[ __ ] up that [ __ ] is
yeah punting a cat you're just like hey
come here come here look come to this
danger point so i can kick the [ __ ] out
of you into a [ __ ] seat yo have you
all seen this [ __ ] it was like uh last
week or two weeks ago
dude this dude was uh it was in la of
course uh this dude
this dude was hitting this dog like
[ __ ] oh my god
and [ __ ] bystanders saw what was
going on and they beat the [ __ ] out of
this dude
they [ __ ] this dude broke his legs
dude oh dude he saw that [ __ ] luckily
the dog was okay like it was like
terrified he was like dragging the [ __ ]
around the dog yeah exactly a bomb or
just some dog walker i don't know yeah
he could have been absolutely dog walker
so
welcome back to bum or dog walker
i would love to find out that that's not
why it's just that he was a yankees fan
just something similar
what the [ __ ] that happened
this was the the la incident um
you don't see the dog you just see the
aftermath of the guy yeah you see him
getting his ass b
let's see it's the greatest it's the
greatest i won't feel this i won't feel
like it's upsetting or just it would be
satisfying warning oh morning extreme oh
damn the guy was working bro the guy
wasn't working
there's a construction worker
oh
that's a small dog
did you just see
how it brought the community together
like there was a white construction guy
it was some black
they look like the village people but
like just attack
it totally did
that's so funny
[Laughter]
yeah right
now send these guys like the suicide
squad into the yulin dogfights
[Laughter]
wasted those [ __ ]
look they're coming in with via plane
like [ __ ] parachute again
with the same outfits they still got
that [ __ ] became a double dragon game
the enemies were so assorted right
yo they beat the [ __ ] dude that dude
that [ __ ] stink was just [ __ ] so
did any of those people face charges do
you know hell no
they all got purple hearts
[Laughter]
keys to the city
everybody has their own holiday in the
city
i pledge
allegiance perspective jobs
you're a foreman now for that [ __ ]
what was that thing you hit them with
it was like a two by four by 12. has the
camera and he's like looking at like
[ __ ] was huge huge
yeah it's like rough [ __ ] once you
break it down that tripod leg from you
know when they're like looking at you
[Laughter]
why that i wanted it to break it half so
that he would just have no one had to
just
you know a bat looks aggressive but a
long stick just looks hilarious yeah
it's hilarious yeah him 20 seconds to
lift it up
yeah
it's a totally different conversation
it's like larping yeah yeah it's not
assault you know because he also got way
close and that thing had some range yeah
it took forever to [ __ ] get down
i bet he missed every time
he was like what he's doing the other
way
he's the homies
[Laughter]
every time he swings your back
sorry it was big enough
who hit his friend behind him
dude he hits the dog and the guy's
turning up
sorry he was a mistake
he hits the dog i love dogs i love dogs
i love dogs
i'm trying to hit him i'm sorry the dog
ends up on the end of the stick
[Laughter]
yeah right
but the way they were jumping the dude
looks hilarious oh it looks so funny now
some guy was punching it looks like
watch it again to watch everyone
everybody let's break this down we got
to break this down
i put it in slow-mo or something dog
beat up
and it was the first thing
that's so funny oh my goodness
there's a longer club
[Music]
wait wait i have to say hold on timeout
i didn't i didn't i talked a lot of [ __ ]
in this video i didn't know the dog
what is the
yeah no one's asking this question ain't
no dog disrespecting me
you got his face
to judgment yeah
yeah you're right we gotta empathize
yeah what did he say we didn't see the
whole footage yeah we spoke we spoke too
soon i'm like wait wait wait wait he
talks [ __ ] first
see he's like [ __ ] did you hear
what he said to me
that changes the whole conversation yeah
disrespecting what it looks like he
disrespected me back
wait i got to hear the dog disrespecting
me
speaking to her
baby oh my god
he said he didn't think the dog was hurt
he already beat him up like this he said
yeah yeah you said hit that dog
you ain't [ __ ]
if i was one of the dudes jumping them
i'd be mad at the dude with the stick
i'm like dude what the [ __ ] you doing
like why are you [ __ ] too much run
just you use your feet dog
do what i'm doing dude you see me with a
weapon
yeah why you got a [ __ ] stick the
dog's disrespecting me he didn't obey me
it does happen though if you guys have
been a dog owner and you're like you're
like okay you're like this dog always
sits whenever i say sit and then like
hey sit and then does it sit when all
your friends are around yeah are you
like
really you're gonna do this right now
wait till we get home
everybody in front of everybody making
me look like a fool in front of
everybody every time you swear to your
friends your dog does something they
don't do it whenever they're alive oh
yes disrespectful man
so you try to tell the construction guys
like hey look at what he can do right
that's what it was
just in socks
there's also that one dude who's in the
fight who like his ass is out so he
could pull out his pants watch watch him
out yeah watch you can see it you can
see his ass crack the people who beat
the man for nearly a minute
[Laughter]
they still have that citizen's arrest
that's great yes yes it doesn't seem
like they've honestly i don't think i've
ever seen it happen i've never seen it
happen
i don't even know how to correctly do it
yeah what do you want to do
you have to have a spear yeah is there a
citizen's arrest in nevada nope i don't
know how this works kill people
do you get like you know how like with
if you had zip ties and you restrained a
person do you get like a kidnapping
charge or something like that or like a
hopefully matt nevada is not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i would not want to [ __ ] do a
citizen's arrest no way i'm like bro
[ __ ] what if it's with the [ __ ] he's
got zip ties
and we see some crimes going down yeah
but it's a little like safety patrol for
me
hallway monitor he calls ems dude
you know you know what's funny if i
really think about it if i like saw some
crime or something going on i don't know
if i would like jump in and try and stop
it i would just go away yeah but if i
saw somebody being an animal oh yeah
[Music]
right yeah
because like at what level are you
allowed to citizens arrest like if
someone was doing graffiti obviously
that's too low level that they would
probably be like don't citizens arrest
well it was dope graffiti it was dope
graffiti let it go
you start watching oh that's just tight
he starts doing it better he's like oh
[ __ ]
what's your ig man i like your man
really nice colors if you see a little
girl getting kidnapped you're like i'm
just leave it alone but then there's a
dog getting kicked didn't you stop well
why'd you throw little girls i know
right yeah you definitely just told me
i hate white people
and he's [ __ ] ending with this
i think people would respond to amber
alerts better if it said dead or alive
like catch this guy catch this guy
amber alert
reward a million dollars everyone's
doing it everyone's doing it i can't
wait to citizens arrest everybody i
would stand by a liquor store and wait
for a kid to [ __ ] steal some bubble
gum so i could grab his [ __ ] ass and
be like citizens arrest you son of a
[ __ ]
six year old [ __ ]
that sounds so weird that like if
somebody said
how does citizens arrest work if like
you're a business owner and you can't
stop a guy from stealing your [ __ ] oh
yeah that's right yeah it's like weird
because they tell you not to run after
the um yeah but then a citizen cat just
not the employees yeah they tell you you
can't do that because of danger but if
you're not afraid of danger you can
arrest them
that's actually the best explanation i
remember one time one of my homies did a
beer run and he ran out and one of the
uh one of the
things he was carrying one of the cases
he was carrying a beer hat fell out and
the [ __ ] clerk [ __ ] picked up the
period through it
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know when it hits their back they do
it
like you guys like you got shot if it's
not an open container that [ __ ] hurts
yeah i know that's so sick
it's dance yeah
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you